[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
air travel is bouncing back in the u.s i
took a flight to get here to new york
on friday tsa checkpoint screened more
than two million people a day for the
first time during the pandemic
but there's a lot more trouble in the
air because of a growing number of
disruptions on planes
these people had to subdue a man in the
middle of a flight over the weekend
errol barnett is at reagan in reagan
national airport outside washington
errol it seems like there are more and
more of these incidents
yeah that's right adriana i'm confident
you were very polite and well behaved on
your flight but the reality is
the faa is reporting there have been
more than 3 000 complaints
of unruly passengers just since january
1. compare that to the past
decade where the agency says it
investigated
1500 incidents total and you're right
for the first time in recent memory
we're now seeing an
off-duty flight attendant as the one
allegedly causing the disruption
and it was all caught on video
this was the chaotic scene aboard delta
flight 1730
friday night as travelers were called
into action
to assist the flight crew in subduing a
disruptive man
and then you hear the pilot from the
cockpit going if there's any large men
on board please come to the front of the
plane immediately we have a crazy
passenger brandon azarian says he was
seated near the off-duty delta flight
attendant who caused the scene
and watch this struggle up close it's a
huge fight they get him down on the
floor
and he's flailing everywhere his legs
are flying in the air his arms he's
screaming there's passengers screaming
especially after a year of being locked
up we're all finally vaccinated
trying to fly trying to travel and just
everyone is acting crazy on plane sounds
making people not want to fly
earlier this month another man was
restrained after trying to breach the
cockpit
on a flight from lax to nashville
while in may this woman was charged with
felony battery
after video showed her punching a
southwest flight attendant
while air rage has been an issue for
decades this surging conflict has some
flight attendants scared
to work that's according to sarah nelson
the president of the flight attendants
association
we are on track to have 60 times the
number of unreally passengers as we
might have had
in a typical year over just the last six
months
the faa says it received almost 3 000
reports of unruly passengers
mostly related to refusing to comply
with mask mandates
people have an idea that on the plane
it's a different set of rules
not to mention all the stresses that
people experienced over the last year
all the uncertainties that they went
through people are
feeling like enough is enough and
they're really acting out and now
they're getting out and wanting to be
free
and the first thing that they have in
front of them is a combat over a mask
now in an effort to curb some of these
incidents several airlines have gone as
far
as to suspend alcohol service but with
longer security lines like here at dca
this morning and more crowded aircraft
the fear is that this may just be the
beginning
of a difficult summer of travel and a
reminder for everyone
including anthony and the rest of us the
federal mass mandate for air travel
remains in effect
until september 13th yeah and i think we
can all put up with it for a little
while longer errol thank you
60 times the number of unknown
passengers people behaving badly
no must be all the anxiety from this
pandemic here but i mean we have to
treat each other nicely i know
i know we can we can deal with this a
little while longer we've gone through
so much